good morning everyone how's it going
gross I am in Japan and today is vlog
day smash like four vlog day if you're
excited today we're going to Kamakura
which I've been to once before we're
gonna recreate the blog step by step
starting now don't know chemic or is
that about an hour away from tokyo south
it's like a beach town i would say we're
not actually recreating come on
goddammit sleepy
we're just exploring what we haven't
done before like making strawberries and
that bamboo for us for sure I really
want to see
[Music]
the Strawberry place is closed but we
have ice cream so cherish there's that
it's like matcha green tea flavor I
don't know if I like it
we're about to go through the same bike
rental we're about halfway there so far
we haven't dined forgot how pretty come
icarus it's so shows like it's pretty
okay it's pretty
we got giant fish easy oh I totally
missed a zoomin there you are found you
yes iam are you done to me mark yeah I
don't turn
surprisingly lack of bamboo if it's not
the bamboo forest
Wow whoa I'm starting to think this is
not the bamboo forest and it's just a
forest she only understands this posture
over there wow so pretty look at this
tree I'm feeling nihongo as [ __ ] right
now
Nihon I mean of course nihongo means
language I knew that edit that out
Marcia please that's a little guy with a
hat down there I'm so glad I'm sharing
this moment with Marcia who's not here
so they're not in full bloom but it's
getting there this is a [ __ ] Japanese
moment guys this was worth the trip just
this tree what a forest of bamboo
there's so many of them
very nice that is so cute why does he
have a hot lap okay this is the real
deal whoa holy damn that's some bamboo
boy whoa amazing I like them big I like
them chunky good joke Felix thank you
please don't cooperate well something
just found a lot of people don't know
this but if you knock on a really big
bamboo special sound will come out you
hear they amazing what a day what a time
to be alive what a time to be a youtuber
everyone we decided we're gonna go to
the center and check out little below
did you just boom I remember buying
honey in Kamakura
that's so good the goal is to find it
again do you remember that work yeah
my assistant yes is anyone Sasuke
this long it will not get more any more
interesting in this just letting you
guys know we're going to get honey guys
minion flavor
what does the minion taste like what are
you doing oh my god we found another one
look at this so it's basically flavored
honey
hmm so good you never think drinking
honey but it's so good mmm it's really
good but not as good as whew
I don't know why I'm filming this we
made it back everyone
hello hello hope you enjoyed this very
fun day very nice not the most invent
--fill shame about the strawberries or
should I say itchy go picking me for
those you are wondering mm-hmm this is
how my setups set up looks like well I'm
here
Thank You Origin PC the laptop actually
it's very handy I learned a little did a
sponsor with them and they were like if
you bring your setup anywhere it's very
good and it is thank you I love how I
can just bring this setup anywhere and
just record it's so cool I'm very I'm
very happy I honestly can't believe this
is happening people are making fun of me
for my height can you believe this can
you believe people are in is I'm 180
also felix wearing shoes you're making
fun of my shoes i am so tall and I'm not
insecure by my high and I'm gonna prove
once and for all if I'm not a 180 then
how come how come it says on my passport
180 huh can you see that point proven
himself try again you man let's 180 is
peak height by the way right Marcia she
says yes anything above 180 and you look
like you have something to prove but you
don't anything unless you look like a
tiny little frog okay 180 guys if you're
180 let me know in the comments because
we need to stand together against these
abuse that I will not stand for anymore
which I can't cuz I don't have legs how
is this me I'm still going up sometime
is von and see you guys on the flip side
as my outro goes flippity flop in
flippity-flop next time darkness then
redness then whiteness learn
[Music]
hey how about that this boring vlog
isn't over - that's been editing it and
we review the footage and we're like
nothing really happened I also realized
how monotone I was like in my blog
compared to my videos this is how I
actually have much a person guys hope
you enjoy it we're doing it guys we're
doing the famous crossing and we have to
hurry up so cool all right we're going
in here oh Jesus why do they have fish
over there oh my god is the eels that's
amazing what
what is this shot Jesus Christ Japan
what is wrong with you oh my god
attack them Thailand laundry detergent
seriously just like Hachiko very well
Jesus wall my god what just happened I
was like it's fine
this shop is interesting very nice they
shop with so many cool figure but
they're so expensive
hey it's boob main you know him
it's a shark that it's also a
transformer amazing vintage devil men
pretty cool
hey I'm a blue-eyes White try again
while you just dark magician no wait
there it is
wait nailed it I think this is one of
the cards they sends her in the West
this one because the a hatch boobs can't
have that in the West that's honestly
dope I'm kind of tempted to buy that
what is this together maybe
[Music]
Siri
[Music]
we're here at Magura river they got the
lanterns lit and they're supposed to be
cherry blossom I have an Android it's
really good camera yeah because it's an
Android and it's really good camera
androids have Anders have the best
camera I'm really glad we came at night
because he's really see everything
[Music]
night time Sakura everyone Sugoi desu
man
whoa they're everywhere
hope this extra bonus part of the vlog
made up for it very exciting lawns
changing the game instead of making them
super fun and X my god what is that but
yeah hope you guys enjoyed this vlog
hope you guys King enjoyed coming along
how do i vlog it completely forgot how
you do it smash like subscribe we can
still be t-series or something like that
goodbye sayonara bye bye